Well, good morning. Good morning. Morning boy.
It's good to see you this morning. I am, uh,
delighted to walk through and close out this, uh,
sermon series on the book of Joel with you. And, uh,
today is, uh, really,
it's a tough passage of scripture to preach and that's why I'm finishing it
last. Um, it's Joel three one through 16,
but because of that, I'm gonna ask a favor of you. Okay?
Okay. Nobody responded. That was, I'm gonna ask a favor of you, okay?
Okay, good. Y'all gonna have to get alive. I mean, this is, summer is here,
right? It is good. The sun is out. We're gonna have fun,
but I need a, I need a favor. All right,
so today's topic is pretty heavy,
so I'm gonna ask you if you would just give me a few minutes, all right.
Give me a few minutes today.
So if I could invite you to please limit your social
media activity or your texting,
or if you're developing your list of groceries for what you're gonna buy at the
grocery store today, please put that off for just a little bit.
Give me a couple of minutes. Can you, can you do that for me? Yes. Okay.
Everybody over here was like nothing, right? So apparently no.
Are you guys, is that okay? Can you give me just a few minutes? Yes. All right,
cool. All right. So here's the deal.
Today we're looking at a passage of scripture that is hard
to deal with. It's, it's heavy, and, uh,
so we'll walk through it together to get us where I want us to go. Uh,
let me first of all say thank you for the opportunity to preach here for this
past few weeks. It's been awesome. I love your pastor, I love your elders, and,
uh, it is just great to be with you. So thank you so much. Uh, second thing,
let me just say thank you for your continued prayers. Obu,
u's gonna have a 12 to 24 month recovery period. And so, uh,
pray for us, work with us. Uh,
if you see stuff on social media or in the news or whatever,
continue to pray for us or help us in any way that you can, uh,
and we'll be grateful. Third thing to get us,
I want you to, uh, understand something.
When I approach scripture,
one of the things that I do is I bring my experience to it,
and I can't help that we all do that. But some of our experiences,
my experiences in life are kind of strange. One of those experiences is, uh,
if you don't know this about my wife and I, we moved to the uk and, uh,
when we moved to the uk, uh, life turned, uh,
in a really unexpected direction. We had, uh, our daughter,
our oldest daughter who just graduated high school. She was born over there.
Our oldest son was about four or five months old when we went over there. And,
uh, I got to serve in two churches while I was there. It was wonderful.
One of those churches, and you may not know this about the uk,
but they have different class levels over there. Uh,
you have aristocracy and you have kind of the common class.
And one of the churches that we served, um, they had two,
uh, lords in that church. And Lords.
I mean, what is a Lord? I mean, what is that? I know about it. Uh,
only because of the Christmas song. Uh, what is it? Seven Lords are leaping,
right? That's it. What is the Lord? I have no idea.
But I learned about 'em while I was over there because, uh,
they were aristocracy. It was a certain class of folks.
And I remember one time one of the lords in our church, uh,
and he had this very kind of highfalutin accent.
He said, oh, you know, Charles came by the other day.
Charles, who's Charles? Is he in charge? I mean,
what are we talking about here, Charles?
And at the time it was Prince Charles came by his house.
What you need to understand is his house was this very old church.
The church that I had served had been a sight of Christian worship for a
thousand years. And so it was a very old, uh, church.
The building was old and stone. And the, the house that our,
the Lord lived in was right next to the church.
And he was talking about Prince Charles. Now,
king Charles was coming to his house for a visit. I said, really?
Wow, what kind of car did he drive? He said, oh, he flew
what? Yeah, landed his helicopter right there on the lawn. Of course, as you do,
apparently. So why am I telling you this story?
Because that was a momentous event in this lord's life.
The Prince was coming to visit. Now let me ask you a question.
What if Prince, now King Charles came to your house?
How would you prepare? What would you do? Well,
I think probably you would get some really good food like Chick-fil-A
and serve it to 'em. Or maybe Chicken Express. Who's the better Chicken?
Yeah, I like the fact that you have opinions on this. This is fun, right? Right.
It's clearly Chick-fil-A, although chicken express is pretty good.
I've probably missed a chicken place, I'm sure. Don't say Popeye's, just,
just don't. I'm, I like Popeye's. What am I talking about?
You'd bring some good food out, wouldn't you? You would clean the place up,
right? That grime that's been sitting on the island for three weeks,
maybe this is just my house. You'd, you'd clean that up.
You'd make sure that the dogs haven't destroyed something. Or if you have a cat,
I'll just pray for you, right? And we have a cat too.
You would clean the place up because the king is coming.
You wouldn't just kind of let things slide. You'd mow the grass,
trim the hedge, prepare weed, the garden.
You do all those things cuz the king's coming and
that visit would impact how you prepare for
your time between now and then.
Why do I tell you that story? The reason is,
is because actually there is a king who is coming
and his name isn't Charles. This dignitary is much more significant.
It's king Jesus. And whether, you know,
you sit wherever you sit on this journey of faith, right? Some of you, uh,
in the room may, may not be, uh, followers of Jesus at all. Uh,
I you're warmly welcome here.
Some of you may be followers of Jesus for a very long time.
You're warmly welcome here. Some of you may be kind of, uh, on the journey
and you don't really know what you believe. You're not antagonistic,
but you're not really committed. You're very welcome here.
What I'm gonna share with you today is no matter where you are on the faith
journey, here's what you need to understand. The king is coming
and from our text in scripture, he's coming as a judge.
And we need to understand that because that day
needs to impact today.
All right? And we get this from the passage of scripture.
We're looking at Joel chapter three, verses one through 16.
The topic of today's, or the title of today's message is the Judge is Coming.
So if you have your Bible, turn to Joel chapter three, beginning in verse one.
Uh, beginning in verse one,
the text reads this, yes, in those days, and at that time,
when I restore the fortunes of Judah and Jerusalem,
I will gather all the nations and take them to the valley of
je fat, fat. What are we talking about here?
I'll unpack that word in just a minute.
I will enter into judgment with them because there, because of my people,
my inheritance, Israel,
the nations have scavenged the Israelites in foreign countries and divided up my
land, they cast lots for my people.
They bartered a boy for a prostitute and sold a girl for wine to drink.
So what the Texas is talking about is nations clearly enemy nations that are
against God and his people. These enemy nations have trafficked human beings,
particularly the people of Judah, Jerusalem. They've trafficked not just adults,
they've human trafficked boys and girls. Now,
I don't know what your experience is with the Bible,
but sometimes I'm reading the Bible and I'm going, why is that in there?
Because it's a hard text. This is one of those, but it gets harder.
Look at verses four through eight.
Verses four through eight is kind of like an expansion on verse three.
And it gets further detail to that picture.
And also tire Sid and all the territories of Felicia. What are you to me?
God is speaking. Are you paying me back or trying to get even with me?
I'll quickly bring retribution on your heads for you took my silver and my
gold and carried my finest treasures to your temples.
You sold the people of Judah and Jerusalem to the Greeks to remove them far from
their own territory. Look,
I'm about to rouse them up from the place where you sold them.
I'll bring retribution on your heads.
I'll sell your sons and your daughters to the people of Judah and they will sell
them to Thess, to a distant nation. For the Lord has spoken. Woo,
that's heavy duty stuff. I'll come back to it at the end of the message.
Verse nine, proclaim this among the nations. Prepare for Holy War,
rouse the Warriors.
Let all the men of war advance and attack beat your
plows into swords, your pruning knives into spears.
So the image here is those instruments that are designed to cultivate for
life, which are, uh, pruning hooks. That means that you're,
you're taking excess
limbs and whatnot away from, uh,
fruit bearing trees like olive trees or uh,
apple trees or pro pomegranate trees or fig trees. All that,
that's pruning. And then, uh, it says, uh,
beat your your plows. Plows, as we all know is or or for planting,
right? So he is saying,
take these instruments that cultivate life and make them instruments of death.
Now we have the inversion of this picture in for instance, uh,
Micah and in Isaiah where it's God's vision of restoration
is, uh,
turn your swords into plow and turn your,
uh, spears into pruning hooks.
So we have the inversion of this in a restoration Oracle and Micah four and
Isaiah two. Uh,
but here it's take those instruments of life and cultivation of life and make
them instruments of war. Let even the weaklings say,
I'm a warrior. Come quickly, all you surrounding nations, gather yourselves.
Bring down your warriors there. Oh Lord,
let the nations be aroused and come to the valley of Jehoshaphat.
There's the second right jehoshaphat, okay, what does that mean for there?
I will judge all surrounding nations.
Swing the sickle because the harvest is ripe.
Come and trample the grapes because the wine press is full.
The wine vats overflow because the wickedness of the nation's is extreme.
Multitudes.
Multitudes in the valley of decision for the day of the Lord is near in the
valley of decision. The sun and moon will grow dark.
The stars will cease their shining.
The Lord will roar from Zion and make his voice heard from Jerusalem.
Heaven and earth will shake, but the Lord will be a refuge for his people,
A stronghold for the Israelites. Now you might be thinking,
holy cow, what are we looking at today? I told you it's a hard text.
So in the time that I have,
I just really wanna focus on two reflections from this text.
And the first one might seem counterintuitive. We've just heard about, uh,
God's battle against the nations where all these instruments of life are
now transformed in instruments of death and war.
So what's the first reflection that's counterintuitive?
Here's the first reflection that might seem counterintuitive.
Are you ready Again, y'all have to talk, right?
Are you ready? Okay. Yes. Good.
Here's the first reflection from this passage.
We see this truth.
Divine blessing is certain I told you it's
counterintuitive,
but we get it from the bookends of this passage in verse one and verse 16,
look at verse one. Verse one says,
when I restore the fortunes of Judah and Jerusalem and then in verse
16 it says,
the Lord will roar from Zion and make his voice heard from Jerusalem.
Heaven and earth will shake,
but the Lord will be a refuge for his people.
So bookending, this
clear presentation of divine judgment.
You have a picture of restoration and refuge.
Why?
Because these verses are drawn from the Old Testament story.
This language of restoring the fortunes is language that shows up in the minor
prophets at various places.
But it's always picturing God's commitment to his purposes, to renew,
restore, and bless Israel. Why?
Because the story of Israel is a story of divine blessing.
Now let me unpack that for a minute.
This language of restoring the fortunes of his people means that when
God comes to judge, there are those,
namely those who have been faithful to him. Uh, even in hardship.
They've stepped across the line of faith and they've said, we are your people.
You are our God.
God is gonna restore the fortunes of that crew.
It's more than just a geopolitical entity on a map. Why?
Because probably at the time in which this text was written,
there really wasn't a geopolitical nation called Israel or
Judah. So it's a theological reality. It's a theological category.
And he's talking about those people that stay faithful to the Lord no matter
what the cost.
And he's going to restore them to their place as his people
under his rule, the kingdom of God.
That's what he's talking about.
And then he says in the day of judgment, verse 16,
not only will he restore their their fortunes, he's going to be a refuge.
And that means divine judgment is coming.
But divine blessing is the purpose.
Judgment is coming, yes, but God is a refuge on that day of judgment. Why?
So that when judgment comes,
they are preserved and blessed. That's the picture.
Now what you and I need to understand about this passage is it's building out
from the Old Testament story.
Why does God insist on restoring the fortunes of Israel? Well,
one idea might be this. Some of you might be thinking,
I know why God's restoring that pe,
that group Israel or Judah Jerusalem is because God plays favorites.
He likes these people. He doesn't like those people. He likes Israel,
but he doesn't like anybody else. God's racist.
Or maybe he's xenophobic. He doesn't like strangers or foreigners.
That's completely wrong.
I know what we might think that way cuz it kind of reads that way.
But when you read this text in its larger Old Testament story context,
what you I gotta understand is the people of Israel are not just a nation.
They are a people for a purpose. And the purpose is very simple.
Through this people, God is going to bless the world.
How do I know that?
Because the story of Israel is part of God's rescue mission to
renew and restore the entire world.
We know this from Genesis one to three. What the reality is,
is God created a world that is good, but human beings your story.
And my story is that we look at the world that God has made and say, yeah,
that's fine, but I wanna live my own way.
It's like that Fleetwood Max song. You know that song, right?
You can go your own way. Now you might not understand the words I just said,
Fleetwood Mac, but if you didn't, you need to get out more.
That's a great song. You can go your own way.
Well here's what happens when we go our own way,
what happens in your life? What happens in the life of Adam and Eve?
According to Genesis three, when we go our own way, things break
and they break bad. It's like this. When Adam and Eve,
our first human couple, when they sin against God, they go their own way.
They say, I really can do what I want. I don't need to live God's way.
It's like the entire creative world goes like this and their lives
do the same thing. The world is complicated by uh,
that thing that we call human sin.
S i n is a three letter word of terror that wreaks havoc in our
lives.
And so the story of humanity from Genesis three onward is a story of
sin.
Breaking a apart and fragmenting God's good world, sin fragments everything.
Now, God could have junked the world at that point. He could have said, ah,
these humans, I'm gonna start all over, but God doesn't junk the world.
Do you know why
God doesn't make junk?
So if God has created you and I,
you need to understand He created you and I for a purpose and
he doesn't junk us because he doesn't make junk.
So what God does from Genesis three onward,
and he does it particularly in Genesis 12 to 22,
we see this picture of God raises up a people for himself and it's a
family. It's the family of Abraham.
And what the text says is God called Abraham out of what is
modern day Iraq.
And he called them out of modern day Iraq and he called them to
serve him. And he says in Genesis 12, two to three,
he says, I'm going to bless you. I'm gonna make your name great.
I'm gonna give you a family. And then he makes this statement.
He says, through you,
all the nations of the earth will be blessed.
The story of Israel Abram's family is a story of God's purpose
to bless the world that he has created and he does so by raising up
a particular people to be a blessing to everybody else.
So it's God through the particular people that is that family of
Israel.
That family of Israel is designed in God's purposes to turn back the
curse
of sin and be a blessing to all of us.
That story gains further clarity in Genesis, in uh,
the book of Exodus where that family has been delivered from Egyptian
bondage, the people of Israel, that family of Abraham. And God says in Genesis,
in Exodus 19, verses five through six, their purpose. He says,
I've called you out of all the nations of the earth.
You are my treasured possession and I'm gonna make you a
kingdom of priests and a holy nation, a kingdom of priests.
That means they're sons and daughters of the King, king Jesus.
And they are to be a priest like kingdom.
How is that possible? Well, you gotta understand priests in the Old Testament,
they did a few things. Number one, they prayed,
they stood in the gap between others and God, that's what priests did.
So Israel is now standing the gap between the nations and God,
they're praying for the nations and they're teaching the nations God's law.
That's what priests do. They teach, they pray and they stand in the gap.
So Israel is to be that. But here's the big kicker.
If Israel's gonna be a kingdom of priests, they have to be a holy nation.
That means pure and undefiled set apart for God's purposes.
And this is where Israel's story mirror mirrors the story of Adam
and Eve. Israel's story is they sin too.
And that's a problem. So is God gonna abandon his plan?
No, he swears by his own name that he won't do that.
So in the fullness of time, and this is where it's powerful,
God raises up
a king who is his own son,
who is the true Israel, he's the true prophet,
he's the true priest, he's the true judge.
He's Israel incarnate.
And this one man
fulfills the entire story of Israel. His name is Jesus.
And through this person, Jesus,
the story of Israel is fulfilled. And through this one man,
God's perfect Son,
God completes the story of Israel, which means that by blessing him,
all the rest of the world can experience blessing too.
So when God is saying in Joel three,
one and three 16 that he's restoring the fortunes of Jerusalem and Judah,
he's drawing us back to that story.
God's not saying I like you, but I don't like you. No,
that's not the way that God works. God's not saying like you and I do, any me,
Mindy, Moe, ketchup a tiger by the tote. Now, that's not the way God works.
What God is doing is he is being faithful
to the story of blessing. He began in the family of Abraham,
he's restoring their fortunes.
This is pointing us to the work and the person of Jesus.
How does this happen? How does restoration happen? My friends? It's Jesus.
You know, it's interesting. I don't know if you've ever done this.
I would encourage you to do this.
Read the gospel of Luke and just write down how many times Jesus talks about
blessing, blessing of the poor and spirit,
blessed to those who hunger and thirst for righteousness.
You remember what Jesus did when the little children came running to him,
he blessed them.
What we need to understand is Jesus is not just a dude who lives
in our hearts.
Jesus is God's agent of blessing for your life.
This is who God is.
God is in the business of blessing a broken world,
and he does it through Jesus.
You and I experience the blessing of God when we follow Jesus because Jesus
is the fulfillment of the story
of Israel.
So what you and I need to understand is bookending,
this section about judgment is blessing. Verse one,
verse 16. And those who follow Jesus,
that means what we do is we say, I can't go my own way.
I gotta go your way.
I'm gonna step across the line of faith and submit my very life to you.
Lord Jesus, when we do that, you and I
experience Christ Christ's blessing.
And you and I experience purpose and you and I experience forgiveness in life.
That's Jesus.
So divine blessing is certain from this passage of scripture,
but the vast majority of of this text is talking about something different.
Namely divine judgment,
divine judgment is certain as well.
The final sections here in Joel three depict a time in which God will judge
the nations. Verses two and verse 12 indicate,
the place of this judgment is called the valley of Jha. Fat,
JHA fat in the Bible names mean things. And sure enough,
the name here is significant because it literally means yah.
Judges yahs the word Yahweh, which is the name of God.
So another way to say this is God judges the valley that is
going to be this battle is the place where God judges, what does he judge?
He judges wickedness and sin. Sin.
The valley of Jehoshaphat is the place where God judges wicked and sin.
Now what we need to understand is the value of Jehoshaphat is not a location
that's identifiable on a map. It's a prophetic picture of divine judgment.
And here we see later on in the, in the these verses,
it's called the valley of decision where God's gonna
contend with the nation. So it's a valley of judgment. God judges, jehoshaphat,
it's a valley of decision. That valley of decision,
that language is talking really about a final judgment and an ultimate judgment.
A place where the wicked are going to be revealed as wicked.
And they're not gonna be in God's home, Zion.
But those who have stepped across a line of faith and are faithful to the Lord,
they are people of Zion. And in that day of judgment,
the value of decision, guess what? God is gonna be a refuge for this group,
but not a refuge for this group.
Divine judgment in this passage looks like divine war
verses nine through 11,
speak of Holy war and warriors and battle against sin.
Now, some of us don't like that language war. Ah, Jesus is a, you know,
peaceful. He's not. Here's what we need to understand about this.
The reason this looks like war
is because God is not passive when it comes to wickedness and sin.
And you and I should find comfort in that. Let me tell you why.
Let me just use some words and tell you just how do you feel about these words?
Corruption, injustice,
rape, abuse, exploitation,
greed. How do you, how do you feel when you hear these words?
Some of you feel hurt, some of us feel angry. Some of us feel uncomfortable.
Good, we should do you know why
that stuff is wrong
and it's good that we feel that it's wrong. Lying,
cheating.
How do you feel about these things? Well, if you feel
about that, those words,
how do you think God who is holy,
just and true feels about those things?
God is perfect. God has created a world that is good. God is holy,
God is true.
God doesn't want in his world those things that we feel, know,
sense or wrong. And he doesn't just passively sit by why that stuff is here.
This text reminds us that God goes to war against sin
and these nations that think themselves strong,
the picture here is it's almost like a little spark that's
this big.
It's infinitesimal the spark that's the power of the nations.
And they're coming against God who is the ocean?
What's hope does this little spark the nations have on the day of judgment
against the ocean? They don't have any hope.
That's the point in the valley of decision.
When God judges wickedness and sin here signified by enemy nations that
represent sin,
there is no hope for victory. God wins.
But the point is,
God wins against wickedness and sin.
So divine judgment looks like the judge pronouncing verdict on the wicked.
Look at what the text says. Verse 12. Let the nations be roused,
come to the valley of ssha F for there I will sit down to judge
all the surrounding nations. And that judgment looks like this.
Swing the sickle because the harvest is ripe,
come trample the grapes because the vine press is full.
The vine bats overflow because of the wickedness of the nations.
Is the scream e extreme?
The point here is that God comes to judge the nations and
the verdict is against the wicked. This valley of Jehoshaphat,
it reminds us that
God's verdict against the wicked is sure
it's going to happen. Now, some of us might be be thinking in the room, well,
when is that gonna happen? Has it already happened? When is it gonna happen?
Well, again, the texts give us indications. You know, the the great, uh,
medieval theologian, his name is Thomas Aquinas.
He follows a long tradition within Christian thought who saw the valley of
Jehoshaphat, of the valley of decision here in Joel three.
He connected that to the location of Jesus' final judgment on
the wicked in his tr treatise on last things. His big book was called, uh,
it's multi-volume book called Summa Theolog. And in that book,
he connects this text to Jesus' final
judgment.
And that is in Revelation for instance 14 or Revelation 20
and Revelation 14 or 20, let me just draw your attention to it looks like this.
I'll read in verse four. In, in chapter 14, uh, beginning in verse 14,
then I looked and there was a little, uh, a, a white cloud. And the son of one,
like the son of man was seated on the cloud.
That's Jesus with a golden crown on his head and a sharp sickle in his hand.
And then the angel came out of the temple saying,
use your sickle and reap for the time to reap has come since the harvest of
the earth is ripe.
So the one seated on the cloud swung his sickle over the earth and the earth was
harvested. And then look at verse 14, uh, 18.
Another angel who had authority over fire came from the altar.
He called with a loud voice, the one who had the sharp sickle, that's Jesus.
He says,
use your sharp sickle and gather the clusters of grapes from the vineyard of the
earth because its grapes have ripened.
So the angels swung his sickle at the earth and he gathered the grapes from the
vineyard of the earth and he threw them into the great wine press of God's
wrath.
Then the press was trampled outside the city and blood flowed out of the press
up to the horse's bridals for about 180 miles. Yikes.
So what we need to understand here is when John,
who wrote the book of Revelation has this vision of Jesus,
the vision resonates with what we see here in Joel three.
What we need to understand is this is talking about the final judgment,
the final judgment, where God comes to judge the living and the dead.
The nations who are set against God and the nation, Israel,
new Jerusalem,
the people of Judah and Jerusalem who have remained faithful to Jesus.
This is the reality. This is what this text is pointing us to.
It's pointing us to a final judgment.
The valley of decision,
the place where God is going to weigh our deed. And let me just tell you,
those who are wicked on the day of judgment, it doesn't go well for them.
In fact, revelation 20 pictures this in this way,
those who have set themselves against God
are thrown into the lake of fire.
Hell separation from God forever.
And I know, you know, sometimes we don't like to hear this or talk about it,
but here's the reality, I can't get around it.
It's here in the text. So this is our authority. We gotta,
we gotta understand it.
So this tax is pointing us to judgment,
And it's not vengeful. It's perfect judgment.
And the reason we know this is because it's like verses four through eight,
verses four through eight look horrific because you're talking about human
trafficking. But you gotta understand in the ancient world,
in the ancient world, whatever, a judge gave a verdict of a judge could say,
yeah, I know you've accidentally killed someone in,
in an inadvertent manslaughter, but in the ancient world, somebody could say,
I know you did that, and I know it was an accident. But I tell you what,
this'll be the, uh, the justice, uh,
this person who was affected can go kill your entire family. Now,
is that just no, because it's not balance.
It's not like, uh, equal measure.
What you need to understand is in the ancient uh, world,
that's that's how things work. But in the scriptures,
God gives a different vision of justice. It's called the law of equal measure.
Retribution. You've probably heard it like this. An eye for an eye,
a tooth for a tooth. We might think of that as really harsh.
But in the ancient world, that's extraordinary. Fair,
equal measure, punishment can't exceed the crime.
That's the biblical vision. Why?
Because the law itself testifies to a god of justice.
So you and I might not like the fact
that this exists in the Bible, but here's the deal.
God is not going to allow sin that is creation destroying to
impinge on his holy perfect and just pure world that he is creating.
He's not gonna do it.
And so he's going to judge sin perfectly.
And those who embrace him are going to experience joy.
And those who do not will not. Now,
if that's true, my friends,
if divine judgment is certain,
H
How do we stand on that day
when the king comes? How are we gonna stand?
Today we celebrate what's called the Eucharist,
the Lord's Supper. Maybe you've heard it said,
do you know why it's called Eucharist?
Because in the gospel of Matthew, which I'm about to read,
Jesus gave thanks and broke the bread and
poured the cup,
and he had the meal that we're about to celebrate with his disciples.
And that word of giving thanks is called in the Greek
Eucharist. He gave thanks. So it's the Eucharist.
It's a Thanksgiving meal where we remember what Christ has done.
We give thanks because Jesus
is our way of escape on the day of judgment.
In fact, this day of judgment,
those who have stepped across the line of faith and say, Jesus,
I want I want to live for you. I i want to experience blessing,
not just in eternity, but now
because Jesus shed his blood and his body was broken,
you and I can experience forgiveness of sins
and be reconciled to God.
And I don't know where you are in your faith journey,
but what we're about to do is that celebration.
We remember what Jesus did on the cross. He shed his blood for you and me.
He broke his bodies that you and I might be brought home to God. Jesus,
I love the way that one scholar says this. He says,
Jesus went to the far country of our sin to bring
us home. How can we be certain
that God will be our refuge on the day of judgment?
Look to Jesus and live.
Now we are about to, uh,
embody with our actions. What we have just learned,
what Jesus has done on the cross is
good news for those who rely on him. But for those who reject, uh,
Jesus, it's a word of judgment against them.